when I heard of the the building of
fiber-to-the-home in Sweden the first
thing I thought of was finally I thought
this was the way for my dreams to come
through Aachen Karlsson is a Swedish
film editor who spent years editing
movies during which sunlight was a rare
pleasure and being able to work from
home was a dream many light-years away
but when ftth came to the small village
of Shilla for north of Stockholm Hawken
decided to transform this 19th century
schoolhouse into an editing studio
allowing his dream to become reality
now when I have the fibre to my doorstep
it's possible for me to live completely
another lives than before I mean earlier
I spend 12 14 hours a day seven days a
week and during that time I don't see my
family that much that's for sure
sometimes I need and not in the same
serious to my family thanks to fiber and
the dream of working from home
pakkun Carlson invented a revolutionary
editing tool an internet-based system
called Hawkeye it allows film editors to
work remotely and eliminates the use of
transportation today I can work remotely
with my editing to earlier we have to
fly if producers or directors from
Berlin some 800 kilometers to Stockholm
or from Oslo some 450 kilometers to
Stockholm just to view a version of a
film and today through the hawk eye we
can see the the streaming video instead
of attending or shipping DVDs so we
saved a lot of time and thereby a lot of
money and we also protected the
environment I don't think I actually
really left my editing room when I
worked in Stockholm and nowadays I have
the nature close to my house in my
office so I can have a walk by the lake
or somewhere and not actually thinking
about my job and things but when I come
back to the office I have solved things
during my walk I would say
I am thanks to the fiber-to-the-home I
can end my day almost whenever I want to
I don't have to finish things before I
can go home I can just leave them go
home and eat dinner with my family and
then hook up from my laptop at home and
continue wherever I were before
now the way I work today I'm more
efficient I can be wherever I want to be
and we can still do the same things now
my assistant can be in Stockholm which
is 250 kilometers from here and just log
into my computer or do things together
with me and help me out the support of
hawk which is 500 kilometers up north
can log-in and help me out with problems
with the avid or something I could also
have collaborations with directors in
Stockholm or producers in Stockholm
the fibre to the home and didn't made my
home closer it made my work closer
you